hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to riddle transfer now this
game john breaux made about four or five
years after the end of riddle school and
I believe that this is like a paradigm
shift in his game development like
ability and style and he came at this it
said in the development log it said that
he spent more time on this game that he
did the entirety of the riddle school
series which can only mean that it's
incredibly amazingly good and I should
be able to do it well and appropriately
and apparently this takes place
immediately after the end of riddle
school 5 well now that your world is
saved on our sadistic beautif is is gone
from the universe what do you all plan
to accomplish when you return to your
life on earth ah wait
oh no he's a fireplace now he's not an
icicle anymore personally I plan to find
a cure for this fever I've developed
create a couple thousand gallons of ice
water might help a little smiley good ol
smiley I'll continue my search for
knowledge and use what I know to help
others oh reading the cyclope diem might
be fun oh that's so nerdy and stupid I
mean smart I haven't really thought
about what I'll do when I get back I
guess what I'll do when I get back is
think of what I'll do when I get back
Phil that's for me ah what's going on
why are we stopped
something that's controlling the ship
well that's never good is it aliens I
mean it can't be aliens considering we
are on an alien ship boy it's taking us
off course he's also coming from Earth
so where are we being dragged to and why
is this against my will I protest this
very much so even though I kind of did
want to go to earth anyway so why am i
complaining about this I'm gonna crash
land no then everything is fine and
hunky oh oh that doesn't look good oh
[ __ ] oh no it's the men in black what
are we gonna do Oh
dicks well yeah we're boned Oh alrighty
then well I guess I can only assume Oh
what does he not get handcuffs Oh cuz
he's special and they want his powers
again
god dammit they wanted to ice before and
they want fire now doesn't make any
goddamn sense
well how's hoping for a new beginning I
just didn't think it would look like
this well tough [ __ ]
get out of there somehow ok so in this
game Amanda hunter Burson used my brain
and I'm gonna use it to the best of my
ability and not [ __ ] anything up here we
go how the [ __ ] it is flusher lid Oh
things I can't tell if they're
doohickeys doodads or watching McCall
it's I don't know what any of that is
but that doesn't look like a handle it
looks like a giant cockroach
[Music]
why am I in it haha okay then I got
something out of it sing mirror to be
safe I'm gonna be insured and I don't
even touch that mirror seven years of
bad luck wouldn't go too well with my
two major back to back of deductions
exquisite betting poster dial pad how
about this thing
can I do something with it husky oh I
don't know one two three four
nothing okay so I don't know the code oh
well that's obviously well that's
incredibly convenient why is that there
seven eight to five five seven eight two
five five point right I somehow beat the
system and got out using the incredibly
convenient CCTV here well your Oh God
okay there's kind of a map but holy [ __ ]
this map is involved not an empty box
[ __ ] dude [ __ ] how am I gonna get
through all these boxes its train to get
there and there and there
hey nice like an elevator key that's
cool right
oh hey go oh [ __ ] dude there's been
backwards nine days since the last
accident okay odd device the Singh says
creature communicator on the side sounds
potentially useful hello hey oh oh why
is there man at the end of your name no
idea I'm just really goat so having the
time of my life eating grass and strange
mushrooms I was taken away mistaken for
a mythical creature so you were
kidnapped huh uh yeah me too I'm sad
grass is my favorite thing to eat in the
whole world but this grass tastes so
bland it isn't anything like the grass I
used to eat soft grass to last a
lifetime sure but what's the point if it
doesn't taste like grass
I really can't relate to your problem
but I'd like to help out I don't do my
business here in the grass no grass
deserves that it's a great little drain
in the ground that flushes itself
automatically I'd showed it to you but
it's off screen
I'd rather not see it and I'd rather not
see that be used because why would I
want that it's a random pipe I don't
know but occasionally soda cans and
cereal boxes fall out of it it's really
random
the cans inanity every time always
disappointed why do you have a smoke
detector the smoke detector is here so I
can be spared if the grass starts
burning I really care more about the
grass than I care about my cell phone
it's gone not a good side all right talk
to you later okay goodbye
so I got an animal communicator hello
zone 5.1 guard agents annual day off oh
nice oh cool convenient okay so I have a
key for the elevator which means that I
will be able to do what I need to do I
can access all of the floors holy [ __ ]
so I'm on f2 let me go up to f3 first
what did I just slide out there without
walking suppose I did ok hello no
handles hinges or anything unless you'd
normally find on the door no way to
unlock it
hello hey Pig oh hello
what's shakin bacon right now I'm a free
as a bird and bird cage okay
it's a flying pig from the other game
oh don't cage him up like that I'm not
an expert but I can fly yeah I remember
because I saw I was half asleep sitting
outside this building some guy carried
me inside then he locked it up here and
maybe eat like a pig that's a pretty
pathetic way to be captured how do you
exactly do you eat like a pig I know my
etiquette but the guy didn't offer me
silverware or even the napkin so I do
use my feet sure it was fun but not
exactly clean all right bye okay that
was not useful at all okay good bye new
new new oh it's a trashcan from the
downstairs oh wow keep doing that
eventually I'm gonna stop that's good
[ __ ] good [ __ ] right there hello oh
hello hi Zack yeah how are you a little
tied up not a lot I can do you have to
burn the rope I remember that game that
is a great game I've tried that the
flames on my head just don't reach the
rope
keep trying you're on fire you know the
code has five digits and the digits are
one two three four and five but not
necessarily in that order
the first digit plus the second digit is
equal to the third the second digit is
two times the first digit the second
digit is half the fourth digit and the
fifth digit is the sum of the first and
fourth digits I'm not enjoying that's
literally one two three four five you
literally just said Zack you're an idiot
yep
the codes just a simple rising set of
consecutive numbers out of curiosity how
could you have known with Kobo's there's
written on this side of the door by Zack
I open the door if you could get the
[ __ ] out on your own I sure did it for
myself oh I don't know I need to do it
for you i Flor what Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
lissa so you tell you some song
gentleman on what subject shall we speak
up on this fine day get band monkey dude
you ain't got no power over me Punk I do
what I wanna do it's a purpose of your
smoke detector family you jazz the walls
are almost completely coated with wood
and vegetation I was only wondering if
it had any of the purpose have you
sometimes used it as a dinner plate
sometimes how do you do my apologies but
perhaps you could spy the nature of your
inquiry what are your emotions in the
grand scheme you told me to remind you
not to ask about that again all right
aren't you gonna remind me okay don't
ask about that again thank you much prim
primate the fawn of crumpets alas
crumpets suffered a faint memory for
this old hominid there were treasures to
behold when paired with the tea leaves
of what was once my forest it was
brother day the blackguard man captured
me that I sipped my very last sport of
tea unjust judgment can be a depressant
like no other okay all right Tallyho
don't know what to do with you guys yeah
this is the only one who can fly this
I'll have to free him along with my
friends not that I wouldn't free him
anyway but he does have the remote that
controls his ship as well as the ability
to not crash these things kind of make
an important hello hi you have hair
that's disturbing
hi I'm guessing you want to ask about my
hair yup 100% yeah seeing as you didn't
have any yesterday it's not like there's
much to do when you're stuck in a little
prison cell so I use a can of hairspray
that's over here to pass the time I'll
admit I'm a bit nervous about what
people think of me now that I have hair
no fashion expert but I'd say it looks
nice thanks
okay anyway let's get you out of here do
you know what the code is five one three
three three ah the angelator log mumbled
to code and dialed it in well there's no
three on that door
I have no replacement three so I'll be
back you stay right there Sally
go down to the basement Shiba shabda
where are we going
hello the negotiable snowman hello hi
what's the smoke detector it's so the
hotheads won't come in and melt all the
ice that's some first-class hypocrisy
right there no pawns don't have a whole
lot of hair nothing to be ashamed of I
don't have any hair myself well that's
not thing to say but I don't need
comfort I just don't have fond memories
of when my hair was shaved off I pay you
a die that I found a board game box if
you give me my hair back interesting
which board game learning to shave
terrible game okey-dokey then
so he's got a dice which I could use on
the keypad okay goodbye
Fred let's curtsy got out of wherever
you were I haven't had the same luck
finding a way out dump is dry you really
got the shaft with this room I really
think the people who put us here just
took a bathroom and added an extra wall
anyway I'd love to get out of here but
can't do it myself I'll get you out we
can make a team effort yep since there's
a lot I can do between a wall of
extremely dense glass
okay so team effort other stuff blah
blah blah okay
do you know snores what I'm pretty sure
the password is snus it can't be snores
it's only numbers really I guess this
paper I found was useless
I'm not joking though here maybe it
means something to you or is it upside
down no it's nothing upside down unless
it's to 0 for 5 which it very well might
be this place looks familiar familiar
how does it look like a lot luckier jail
room little but what I really mean it
looks like the school restroom yeah it
makes me feel so much better
it's weird should be a dial pad but
there's none there so we need to find it
so there's one more basement to go and
then we've explored everywhere so I got
to be down to the nitty-gritty oh hello
I'm gonna take this hose you're gonna
mock me can I have your hat someone else
wanted a hat
good day what do you want let's see can
I have your hat oh my hat is only
comfort I have not to mention it covers
my bald spot how are you I pretty much
feel like eating my whole body starting
with my head so I mean you're angry
you're hungry homesick and sick of my
home I turned sixty six billion 145
thousand nine hundred and thirty Tuesday
that's a lot of birthdays oh by my
birthday by its nobody ever celebrated
somebody I'm a birthday nine years ago I
was stolen and forced to live in this
pathetic excuse for a lake well happy
birthday Thanks I've been looking
forward to spending the rest of my life
and don't be bathtub oh I know what to
do
ah I know I know I need the hair spray
from smiley can I have that can it
smiley can I have the hairspray can I
have it
see no I like being bald I just think
the hair spray will help us escape could
you give it to me thank you
[Music]
hair spray maybe not you deny you know
oh it's the negotiable snowman but let
me worry so are you intrude sorry you're
an intruder if I was a connector to
alarm system I could end you right now I
don't mean to spread any trouble I'm
actually trying to get out you mind
keeping your mouth open so I can enter
the room your garden my teeth could turn
you into coleslaw before you could get
through me
only one who would like to come in
though plan to bring all my friends here
to your three human friends the ones
that are trapped I'd like to see them
even get here that'd be with a laugh
actually I'd be majorly ticked off don't
get any bright ideas delay
okay then goodbye but there's a
negotiable snowman here that wants some
hairspray
hello oh nice nice dude nice oh thank
you thank you have a good day
hi there hello you like hair good okay
goodbye I have a die here ah five one
three three three
boink hey you look lovely smiley I think
it would be a good idea to get everyone
to gather at the lowest point of this
building gotcha I'll be right down
boy okay so I got that I'm doing good I
probably need to get some other stuff
but I have a power room access card
whatever the Frick that means oh there
it is okay so I use the power room
that doesn't look good error okay bouncy
lines think it's the OL oh cool I can
flush messy okay so I need to be able to
flush it but good thing I have a flush
handle right here that is very nice
center pipe is like this will not
function otherwise so how in the Frick
uh that's why I need to get oh boy ah
that's not quite right
oh I know it needs to be done I'm an
idiot so it needs to loop back through
this one needs to be here and then it
needs to loop back ah I got these
backwards damnit this needs to be over
here there we go flush that [ __ ] hell
yeah I did it okay goodbye goodbye
goodbye wonder why no one ever brought
you hello welcome to the places but oh
he was so happy and now I get a
yeah it's going so well for me I'm
actually oh hi hi smiley I think it was
in library Stanton does not compute okay
goodbye I got a hat now so I can use the
Hat fur
maybe I could use it for uh mr. big toe
here you want this this is hat fit your
taste it's nice but only that I find it
not to be fancy enough for wearing okay
so I need to fancy the [ __ ] out of this
hat is what I'm getting out of this
don't ever go in there's a room over
here there was no room over there oh I
know I know oh I know oh I know what to
do with this hose oh I I know absolutely
what to do with this that's not what to
do with it so this is what to do with
this hose Oh
oh hell yes seems like a good spot where
where should the end spot go oh oh only
down there for some sweet chlorophyll to
make the grass grow and make the goat
happy oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that works out
incredibly well I don't know why okay
alright then
I'm gonna go say hi to him cuz he's got
to be happy now hello okay goodbye put
one foot on the green grass and you'll
feel the wrath of a thousand pounds okay
why did I do that
why why did I do that that seems like a
good thing to do but why did I do that
oh I need a flower
I need a flower for the Hat please mr.
goat me I need that I need that hat I
need that hat which means I need the pig
I need the pig because he can fly and
he'll fly over and get one damn this I
was feeling smart oh this is the only
flower I can stop and smell without
stepping on the ground oh okay I was
wrong I'm complicated about it okay so
I'm pretty sure I stick this in
I think this Daisy lacks a proper
decorative Flair that would make this
hat look fancier oh come on
what do you mean of course it would it's
beautiful this is what I'm supposed to
do shut the [ __ ] up
Oh aah where I got Titus knees once my
whole body person claims oh that's why
it's important to read this stuff hey
Zach sneeze oh geez so you've got sneeze
powers it's pretty good better than
fries powers I have mixed feelings about
that escape you're welcome
you might follow me for a while why
would mind but you're smart so I'm sure
there's a significant purpose to having
me follow you I do agree but I'm afraid
you can't enter there any rooms with
smoke detectors I'll be content as long
as I get to burn something well that's
that's a bit it's a bit extreme don't
you think can I burn the pile of monkeys
new alrighty then goodbye
what else could I burn ah burn the wood
door burn the wood burn it yes
fire good oh he's so happy oh oh goodbye
goodbye Oh this'll look dapper
oh hell yeah that is so fancy okay so we
need to go Zach won't be able to follow
in here I've got a hat for you sir oh
sure you look so good and creepy and
terrifying and very terrifying actually
okay goodbye now so this is not the
correct one but the one is downstairs
just a little bit too goofy
hey there slap this bad boy on there so
what was the code again sauce so two
zero four five cuz it's usually the
upside-down thing two zero four five oh
five four zero two
okay so small so we're gonna okay sauce
alright stas right sauce god damn it
[ __ ] you man whose numbers which is what
I assumed it would be and if you look at
it upside down it looked like two zero
four five but I didn't even think I
wasted like 10 minutes god damn it it
was five one seven zero two big [ __ ]
- here I'll bring up the picture again
look at snows the ass is a five that's
was evident the Z is a to the O's a zero
that n the misconception is that n was
not an N it looks like an N because it's
written like an N that's it took way too
well that took way too long
smiling Zagar waiting on the bottom
floor down I go I'll tell you what I
can't find it
I think we've done good that might
actually be everybody that in fact is
everybody so hello hi we're all here my
friends seem duval accidentally stumbled
out the heavily secured confinement
cells we roaming out to have a pinic in
the room behind you here to let us in
wait all of you escaped seriously
air or by design I wish you all a Happy
New Year
oh no psychotic frenzy oh [ __ ] uh what
do we jump for it I don't think I
possess the agility necessary to dive
through this chomping teeth well then
I suppose I'll have to communicate I
suppose I'll have to act I suppose we'll
have to burn you suppose we live oh I
suppose what I believe okay goodbye ah
oh that's easy oh yeah okay that's easy
that was those ridiculously easy
alrighty
oh that's so nice yay game saved what
does that mean does that mean I'm only
halfway through the game cuz that would
be a load of [ __ ] oh [ __ ] dude oh no
oh no it's the steel he's brain oh they
suck it out all this intelligence called
longshot but I think this machine might
be reading dis is mine it even looks
like it's retrieving data on the vision
kind of drastic method to gain
information about a dead project Oh
vision was good scheme concocted by the
psychotic alien dictator vis he started
this project to essentially destroy the
whole universe planet earth would be
destroyed had I not found a way to stop
the maniac it's got a taste of his own
poison and the project vision died with
him I don't know if he died oh yeah he
died cuz he got exploded by a meteor I
forgot about that I wonder if the
researchers in zone 5.1 realized this no
matter I came here to free diz and then
this journey through injustice will all
be a pleasant memory okay how do I do
this well that's obviously a
communicator boink good puzzle panels
7-0 that can't be that easy 7 minus 0
equals 7 like like this hey then 6 oh
this is way easier than the other one
that I had the other one was good and
then 0 well that's super easy you like
that oh I gotta make that okay well this
doesn't seem hard either okay and yeah
we're done
okay then we're done with that one that
was easy okay so oh no no it's another
one of these a forever this time oh okay
hey oh I did it that was super easy that
was like really easy kind of looks like
a whirlpool vision DataViz
collected data brain data Hey oh I did
it biz I'm the greatest I've come to
save you are you dead
is he dead he might be dead oh no he's
alive is he this is what aliens do when
they're dead they blink and smile oh it
looks like everyone is accounted for and
everything of that I still have the
remote for the ship now a marvelous hero
lead the way our freedom awaits us okay
sure thing there's anything left to do
we just got to get the fudge out of here
right no not this one I was wrong
good thing you are all in the elevator I
just wanted to make sure the coast was
clear before we make our grand escape
here oh [ __ ] dude
ah [ __ ] man we gotta hurry wait is sorry
but there's no time I got a abandon all
of you oh you'll have to find another
exit what
well the dick I was just joking I didn't
see he actually abandoned us what a
douche nozzle alrighty then how am I
supposed to get out of here oh I know
how we get out of here
oh I know it waits B - oh never mind
then I didn't know how to get out of
here I was gonna think that I had to
rearrange messy Steuben flushes out the
trash that would have been smart that
would have been cool and that's what I
was going for but this is just as good
hey where'd you did you I want to kill
him I want to murder him well geez don't
you think that's a little excessive
Frank yeah love Maron kids oh wait we're
done
I was doing my own thing don't mind me I
was having a good old time making up a
hypothetical scenario where there was
someone that was murdering people but
either way that's the end of part 1 part
2 is waiting for us just around the
corner but we also have unlocked special
features and I want to see what they are
thought process I was gonna make a
riddle school 6 are too many series have
been ruined by unnecessary continuations
after an obvious ending well this is
interesting because this game was always
free so I don't think that one applies
so either way that is riddled transfer
part 1 part 2 I'll be doing in just a
few days here I'll make sure that I cap
off the series and then this game will
finally rest on the shelf and John
Breaux or John a Chrome or whatever his
name is is doing a great job on these
games and hopefully whatever he makes
next has just as much passion put into
it and maybe it'll make him some money
in the future because I think he
deserves it and I think he could really
make some rhythm so thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know we
thought down the comments below and as
always I will see you
[Music]